Wait, this game is loud.
Oh, one second, one second, one second.
Wait, hold.
Hold!
I'll be right back.
Okay, I'm back.
Hello, everybody.
I have my throat tea here.
For my throat is so...
It's so sore!
Oh, heyo!
Hello, everybody.
Hello, hello.
I am in...
I am all funkified today, everybody.
So please excuse if I am a little lower energy than most
days.
Oh!
Ah!
Another year has gone by and it's my birthday!
It seems that I like turning 21 so much that I have done it
three times you guys can do the math three times 21.
wait two four six wait two oh wait 21 21 21.
where did you carry the one do you do you Carry the one.
Happy 21 Season 3!
Spangled Harm!
Thank you so much for the Hakushuwa.
Happy birthday!
Happy happy birthday.
No carrying needed.
I don't need to get carried.
I do it all on my own.
Sometimes.
Except when I was trying to put up a shelf today and I put
in multiple holes because I couldn't do it.
No!
Boko has been dead?
Wow!
Will you be streaming when you've turned 21 times 3?
I don't even think I can turn 21.
I'm still 19!
Thank
you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
And Kino Koda.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Forever 19.
Feel better be, I hope you have a nice stream tonight.
Thank you.
Fully transparency.
I was like, oh my gosh, am I even going to be entertaining
today?
Because I'm all, my brain is all funkified.
I almost canceled the stream to go get ice cream.
but I said no I love Aibu I want to hang out so I came I
showed up I did my duty but also I will be I will be in
Japan next week going for Comeket because because my mama is
the illustrator for this year and she decided to include me
in the illustration as well.
So my face will be all over ComiCat.
Crazy!
Best streamer Minto in her funky groove.
We get a little funky here.
We get a little groovy, funky.
I don't know about fresh, though.
Groggy Minto time is still beloved Minto time.
I don't know if it's groggy.
I don't know.
Hope the spooky game makes you feel even the slightest bit
better, Minto.
Thank you, thank you so much.
Thank you.
We love you too even if funcified.
Yeah I was like I was like Gosh, you know one of those days
when like every you you accidentally put an extra hole in
the wall and you're like Everything is bad and then I was I
was cleaning up and I set up my ps5 Oh my gosh guys It's
like that I was setting up my air fryer It sounds like one
of those jokes, but no, I was like I was setting up my ps5 I
was like, moving stuff around, and I was moving it, and I
noticed this big old, big old dent in it from, I guess I
didn't notice when I had moved, and I'm like, no!
Will you be cosplaying as yourself?
I, no.
I'm, well, I'm not good at, no, I don't want to wear my
uniform.
You know, my main outfit is my uniform, you know.
I'm only 23 and half season two Today What could I get a
funcified happy birthday?
Ariad flames Happy birthday Love to watch you and dance into
an archive Thank you, thank you Mint, I don't think you're
capable of not being entertaining No offense, but I don't
think you have it in you What's that mean?
Hold on, sorry.
The don't know is I heard it.
But it's being a little, it's, OBS is also being funky.
But you know, what I was saying though is like when, like,
it's like one of those things where it's like you stub your
toe or you drop something on the floor and it feels like the
end of the world.
One of those days.
It's all about the he's and she says, meow, meow.
Wait, oh, why is OBS being so funky for me?
Hold on one second.
refresh.
And then everything goes wrong.
I don't even think it's one of those, like everything goes
wrong.
It's just that every tiny inconvenience feels like
everything's going wrong.
You know what I mean?
In hindsight, it's tiny stuff that doesn't, it's like
whatever.
But because you're like so in the moment, everything feels
like a big deal.
Everybody has those days.
And there's nothing wrong.
with having those days.
Hopefully, if you're having one of those days today, misery
enjoys company.
Hopefully I can cheer you up a little bit.
Lump biscuit.
Wait, why is OBS not showing me the donut?
Oh my gosh, I'm so sorry.
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
What if you get ice cream regardless still get that cold
stone?
I think I will.
Hello, my favorite ghost.
to be okay thank you don't say that maddie that's one that
you know when people say that that's when he bursts in the
tears limp basket not the basket hmm
photomaly photomaly photomaly i am back working a job
because these i don't know what Horror games, indie horror
games love putting you to work, baby.
They love being like, hey, your mundane life of working a
photo studio.
One day you're working a ramen shop.
One day you're working a boba shop.
One day you're working a photo studio.
You cannot escape from the horrors.
It's trendy, maybe.
Escapism, but horrifying.
the idea of it is like even your mundane life something
horrifying can happen you know what i mean customer service
is far scarier than any monster truly hello miito and i was
like you gotta say my monday was pretty rough as well no
paint was spilled thankfully but i'm glad i get to hang out
with miito make it all better i'm glad no paint was spilled
but mondays am i right am i right and if if you guys are
having a tough monday i'm having a tough monday i'm not
gonna just leave you alone on your tough mondays right
mintos minted
music is vaguely x files energy oh i hear it i i get it yeah
vaguely been a bit me though hope everything has been good
neck reviews and welcome back thank you thank you so much
we're good we're good we're good so much work yeah but now
work is over except this work I'm putting you back to work
we're going to be what if you what if your dream job is
taking photos of people you could you could just be like hi
everybody I'm at the mall taking photos of people today is
definitely a revenge ice cream day yeah please okay Venmo
you can't say please wait is this a requesting ten dollars
because I have been banned from Venmo I think it's because I
was banned from PayPal VGM's a bit loud oh thank you it's
like it gets loud I think it's the bass in it that's loud
how because I'm a VTuber.
I got, oh my gosh, wait, this is, this is old mint lore.
Yeah, I got, I got, like, mega band from, from PayPal.
I mean, though, I saw idols yesterday.
I'm seeing idols tomorrow, and I'm watching an idol right
now.
Hang in there, beam.
Enjoy Comic-Cat.
Have fun with idols.
I'm jealous.
I want to see idols.
Spill the tea.
Will one day I don't I just they just said I couldn't use
PayPal anymore and I even called them and I was like hello
Mr. PayPal what did I do explain and they were like well
we're not sure actually were they I can't remember to be
honest it was five years ago six years ago but um they were
like oh by the way it's also tied to your social security
account Like, you'll never, you will never pay Pal again.
So, that's bad.
Lance, oh my gosh, thank you so much for the pig.
Palo Minto flying back to work after this last week vacation
with family.
I mean, go back to work tomorrow, though.
I need another week off.
Why do some vacations, I want to go on a vacation that feels
like a vacation.
You know what I mean?
where you just kind of lay there and do nothing i'm
not having a tough monday but i am working the office by
myself tonight yay night shifts oh no but by yourself is
kind of wait what if you're what if your night shift turns
into a horror game you should totally submit it to fears to
fathom i hope you have a good night feel a staycation great
news me though your trip to comic kit doesn't overlap with
the release of master collection volume two at the end of
the month A week after your concert.
Kapo, thank you.
Oh my gosh, wait, I haven't pre-ordered anything.
Wait, do you think I've missed out on the pre-orders?
Bonus stuff?
I hear the Maldives are nice.
Now, who was telling you that?
I should ask Doki if you have our Fears to Fathom email.
Ever got a response?
Okay.
No.
Were there any physical pre-orders?
I didn't see any.
In Japan, there always are.
Yes.
Whatever crime you committed, I'm sure it was very cute.
What do you mean crime?
I...
I committed no crimes.
The crime of...
Okay, forgery.
They're going through all the MGS VODs.
So many of them.
Kinoko!
Thank you!
There will be more also, because I have not played 5 yet
again.
I say again, because I have played it before, but you know.
The crime of being too cute.
Random but thought you should know I recently got a new JP
exclusive transformer named Cobalt Wing who turns into your
boy Ketsuko Ailis.
Your love for Ketsu may have been bullied.
some of my purchase who cobalt wing i'm looking it up right
now
what is he from oh my god oh my god
what he's so cool looking cobalt wing
oh my gosh That's so cool!
Sorry, my throat is all icky today.
Light blue and light blue close to Minto colors too.
Wait, who are you seeing?
Because...
Oh, no, I see the light blue.
Yes, yes, yes.
I was seeing the pink.
The pink is so cute on it too!
I need him?
I have a great need.
I have a ginormous need.
There is a, like, a...
Wait, when did I last say him?
It might have been...
No, it wasn't Comic Kit.
Wanfest?
Usually there's, like, a guy that goes around as Beast Wars
Megatron.
And his cosplay is amazing.
He's like, he's like 15 feet high and poible.
So, so purple.
Speaking of the Ketsu.
Oh, yes.
I do know.
Oh, gosh.
I'm so bad at saying his name, though.
Hats.
Yes.
Actually, it's very funny because there was like that
dinosaur game that had another trailer come out at the last
what game of game something or other we watched summer games
fest one of those watch along and i was like oh my gosh
ketzel but if you look at it the neck is i think it was the
neck the neck implies more so that's the different pretzel
that hatzeke kopterix or Not E3.
What year is it?
Bring back E3.
Nerd!
You're here too!
What does that make you?
But I got so excited about it.
It's Ketzel in our hearts.
Maybe.
They're very similar.
Just, uh, with a, with, uh, you know, um, a Ketzel.
The pretzel.
They're scary, but like, if they came back, they might be a
little less scary because their necks are thinner.
So you ain't getting swallowed by one of those guys, you
know?
You're humans are too big to get swallowed by one.
So still has the pterosaur moe.
Pterosaur.
True.
Yeah, you just get stabbed.
You just get...
fish watch out hey any fish out there I posted a clip of
that and there's a bunch of dinosaur otaku fighting
oh I'm so sorry okay but seriously like at first glance of
course I think I was watching the screen I was like not
processing I saw him and blacked out you know so funny oh it
was the state of play thank you for checking because my
hyper fixation has been triggered the only other ketzel
transformer is magmatron leader of the predicons from jp
only anime beast wars neo he's made of dinosaurs and ketzel
forms his head oh my gosh
magmatron why did we why is there jp only a beast war Thank
you so much for the five gifted.
I love watching Otaku Fights.
Because it's like, it's...
Watching Otaku Fights is like a pure...
It's like, there's something so pure about it, you know what
I mean?
Where it's just like, nerds being like, I'm...
My information is correct based upon this evidence.
Hi, Minto!
Thank you for streaming today, for giving me company since
I'm under the weather.
Miss, feel better.
Feel better.
I was looking up Magmatron.
Can I just say, like, Decepticons is a great name, but I
love Predicons.
Like, it's such a cool, like, yeah.
We're so cool.
I like Decepticons too, though.
There you go.
cool.
Oh my gosh, wait.
Oh, it's so cute.
Beast Wars is just cool.
Love it.
Can you explain why you like Aketsu so much?
I think they're very cute.
And have you ever just, I think it's so awesome watching
them walk.
Or I mean, well, I guess models of them walk.
But they're just so cute and...
I feel the same thing watching stuff of Ketzel that I feel
watching the shoe bill.
You know what I mean?
They're a little dopey but also so deadly.
Yeah, like they're very scary and very cool.
I think it's fascinating that they're so humongous but so
light.
Like in weight.
The wingspan is so huge and everything.
They're just so...
They're just so fascinating, no?
Hey, Mint and FGO right now.
I'm waiting for a specific servant to become available named
Saber Passion Lip.
When she does, I'm going to try hard to get her.
Do you think she's worth it just looking at her?
Let me look up Saber Passion Lip.
That is quite the name.
I'm not going to lie.
It kind of sounds like a stripper name.
Oh, wait.
I've seen her before.
Wait, I've seen her before.
Yeah, I say it's worth.
Big hands and a big heart.
I'd say so, I'd say so.
Wow.
Oh my gosh, she really has nice lips, though.
And a nice...
pair of eyes.
so it is a stripper could be i'm not judging though i'm not
judging og predacons were actually a subunit of animal
decepticons and the lore they went on to find found wait
they went on to find the beast wars predacons after the bot
con war i think i did know that my favorite transformer is
grimlock i love grimlock he's so goofy her poor spine I do I
do see characters like this and I'm like wow do you do you
need like a back support you know for holding your your
weights anyway shall we get into photomalay photomalay the
real horror we got to get to work everybody it's a Monday
well you might not be watching this on a Monday.
It is a day of the week ending in a Y.
Which means we gotta get money, money, get paid, baby!
So, this is a bit of a spooky game.
If you are, if you are sensitive to spooky, then, you know,
we're taking checkies.
We can pretend we're an idol.
We're, like, at an idol show.
Endless mode.
The game automatically saves at the start of each new day.
Okay.
Day one.
The power must be out again.
I should reset the fuse from the back alley.
Oh, that's horrifying.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
We're starting strong.
Oh, my gosh.
My flashlight is terrible.
see anything oh wait was this my store oh so i work i oh wow
how convenient gotta get to work i have work oh my gosh it's
oh this is where you get this is where you stand to get a
shot
It's so over for us.
How could I resist if it's free?
Missing.
You think it's gonna change to my face?
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Hello?
Candy man.
So this whole building is my...
is my home slash photo studio.
is that my van no no surely not i would not i would not be
giving it away for free at least one dollar at least one
dollar i gotta get something out of it somebody in there
oh i should clean up before opening the shop i should also
turn on the light
oh oh ew this oh my gosh disgusting it would be in
everybody's photos grab the broom and clean the stains on
the floor uh was it in the in here oh yes no supplies needed
i'm just that good you live like this no surely surely this
is from the busy bustling day i had yesterday we had a whole
we had a whole uh mini baseball league come in here they
wanted their they wanted all their photos finally doing her
main duty time to open shop baby oh we'll go put this away
I'm a shop owner after all wait what's oh before we open
shop is there anything like clickable I'm looking around
what was that why are you sending that, Seymour.
I'm a vampire, too.
The wallpaper is giving the yellow wallpaper very much.
Are we going to go crazy, insane?
What else we got over here?
Kitties!
Oh my god!
Oh, why am I lagging?
There's my camera.
What's in here?
Oh, when I was a kid, my dad never wanted me to go in this
room.
What could be inside?
The cat mug shots.
They go hard.
Why are we working at night?
All right.
Let's wait for all the customers that are definitely going
to be pouring in.
What's happening?
Oh, hey there.
waiting a long time for this shop to he's been waiting
literally outside for it
it's just me what's just me I want a photo where I look
handsome of course sir my camera my camera check this out oh
oh he's got that oh shucks anime pose to take a valid
customer photo stand on the marked spot and shoot while the
camera mode shoot while in camera mode with the correct
rotation been seeing wet three on my feet a ton recently
when are we getting wet one and two what do you mean we have
a wet one and two
if you're if you're taking a valid photo a green icon will
appear in the top right okay
Oh, okay.
Oh,
I didn't...
Oh, I'm so sorry.
I didn't mean to walk in on you in the hot springs.
Uh, Naru-chan, I'm so sorry.
Please forgive me.
Oh, printing
photo.
Where do you get your photos?
Did you get your photos printed?
Why am I lagging?
I didn't know this took place in Love Hina Universe.
Everything dies.
To transfer photos to the computer or interact with the PC,
to put your printed photos in an envelope, wait, to put your
printed photos in an envelope, hold the envelope and
interact with the photos.
Badoop.
Camera connected, new photos detected one.
Edit.
Oh.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, it's lagging.
Oh, shoot.
Clear.
Okay, hold on.
Aw, shucks.
It's so moi.
What's this do?
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Move?
Oh, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Okay, okay.
Hold on.
I heard something else.
Oh,
that's not white.
That's like erase.
I just heard something bubbling.
Oh, desu!
Desu!
Why am I lagging?
Sorry, guys.
Print.
Oh, okay.
And then it says here.
I need three by four.
Oop, three.
One for me.
Uh, leave.
How's it going, man?
He doesn't want to talk to me.
Uh, envelope.
One, two, three.
Dozo!
Complete your first customer order.
Yahoo!
Set as...
Wallpaper.
Oh, wait.
No, no.
Oh, I didn't save it!
Now I just have him as my wallpaper.
No!
RE4 merchant voice you're an artist, wait.
I just have a random guy as my wallpaper.
No!
It's okay, we have the evidence Taylor.
Wait!
What happened to my work?
No!
Okay, okay, okay.
I got it, I got it.
Oh, man.
Okay, well, Kawhi-Fi this lady.
I'm applying for a passport.
Can it... What was that?
Did I hear something?
Hold on.
I think maybe I need to hold on I put on like some funky
fresh filters and stuff for the game I'm just gonna turn
them off cuz whoa whoa I'm so bright whoa it might be
causing some of the more lag the lag stuff sorry I'm bright
I'm bright oh what just happened there I am I'm back you
want passport you want passport wait no Oh, I'm still
lagging.
Is it the settings?
Maybe, like, not.
Oh, my gosh.
Maybe, like, a 60.
I'll turn on V-Sync.
Uh.
60?
Maybe I could just turn it on them.
Sorry, everybody.
One second.
VTuber problems.
Okay, wait.
Then I'm going to go back to the lighting.
There we go.
Ooh.
Ooh, it's spooky.
Just some VTuber problems.
Okay.
Okay, we're good.
We're good.
Nice.
Oh, I thought her leg was like...
I don't, hey, you don't need to look, you don't need to do
all that for a, where do, oh my gosh, it just does that
sometimes, okay, I can't believe this guy is my wallpaper,
um, I need, actually, it's like, supposed to be, for a, for
a passport, I need, like, very close up, no, but it's saying
it's not a valid photo.
It has, I don't get the green dot.
Am I?
Am I crazy?
I'm not getting the green dot.
Maybe if I zoom out.
I am rotating.
You guys?
It's not giving me the green dot.
I'll try it anyway.
Yeah, see?
Um.
Step back a little bit.
I'm on the dot.
I'm on the X.
Oh, there we go, there we go.
Okay.
Alright, ma'am.
Oh, there we go, okay.
Say cheese!
Oh, gosh, she scared me.
They get up so fast.
Oh, I heard my own footsteps and they scared me.
Alright, lady.
We have amazing filter service to give you... Okay, so if I
edit it... Oh, save is right!
It's right.
Right there.
Okay, okay.
Very fancy passport photo.
What if we make her Goku?
The game did not like that.
Wait.
Clear?
Oh, that's okay.
She can be Goku.
Okay.
I wish there was a fill function, right?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, oh, yeah.
Cloud?
No, Goku.
You'll see it once he's fully colored in, you know.
Once the hair's all colored in, you'll be like, that's
that's Goku.
I can't see my mouse anymore.
There we go.
Yes.
That is indeed not Goku.
No, I said it is Goku.
Cleaning or cleaning your eyes?
What was that?
Oh, wait.
Where does he have blue on?
Where does he have his blue?
Uh.
I think it's like undershirt.
Whoa.
Sick.
Alright, save.
And I need...
Okay, we need...
We need two by three, five count.
Oh, we have an ink level.
Okay, good to know.
Oh, yes.
Ma'am, you will be thrilled.
And this is all for free.
Okay, I have five.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, wait.
Okay, I grabbed them first.
One, two, three, four.
Okay.
Dozo.
Not gonna lie, I kind of forgot what she looked like.
Oh man, Goku's from Blizzard Orm.
I don't like that.
Oh,
turn off my lights!
They're sending me to the back alley again.
with your pipes don't mind the noises is that a cloud gosh
dang it oh I accidentally turned my own
oh they printed a photo of me where I look awful on my
missing person poster wait a second wait you're missing I
want you to take a better one oh oh he's not missing he just
doesn't want to be Are you the missing link?
Oh.
All right, man.
Why is this so hard sometimes?
Why is it so hard to get the dot?
It doesn't ever show up.
Oh, there we go.
all right we're let's get him let's get him like a real
action shot something he's like gonna be all right already
throw your hands in the air whoops oh whoa whoa buddy whoa
whoa whoa buddy i'm breaking work and i'm sneaking in a
quick quick hint of mintonium it's gonna get her good luck
with the work big overtime is keeping me held down don't
they realize my kamiyoshi is streaming they'll never
understand they'll never understand yeah he seems a little
dizzy whoa he looks like he's about to fight
oh what should we do wait are they gonna put it um he wants
something that will look good for his missing with for his
missing poster mmm boxing gloves make him snake
Okay.
Yeah, that's good.
That's good.
I kind of see it, honestly.
Oh, wait.
Hey.
Oh, this is erase.
Okay.
Lovely.
Are we going to get haunted by a clown?
We'll make him No.
Wait, oh shoot, there's no undo button.
Oh my gosh.
I have to commit to any bit that I do.
But that one just looked ugly anyway.
Okay, hold on.
We gotta give snakes a little like, you know.
There we go.
His hair.
Yes.
Wait, is this brown?
What color did I click?
Did I click this color?
Yeah, I did.
Okay.
It looks so like kind of chocolatey.
Like a milk chocolate.
Mmm, milk chocolate.
Mmm.
The missing poster is because he kept them waiting.
Yeah.
Mmm.
I want chalky milk.
Um.
This is fine.
This is, this is, this is good, isn't it?
No.
He can't be solid.
Wait, gosh, I have to stop committing to the bit.
Oh my gosh.
I have to stop, like, not.
I draw it and then I regret it.
you know okay hold on okay we'll do we'll do big bush
no solidus no solidus
never stop committing to the bit and we'll say um oh my gosh
wait what's the shirt he wears in peace walker snake peace
walker oh that i want the mountain dew one the mountain dew
one hold on Mountain.
Wait, what was that?
Oh, Mountain Dew.
The Banana one?
No, the Mountain Dew one.
Okay, hold on.
Check it.
It's already got the shirt, right?
But then the Mountain...
Oh, do I want to fill it in?
Yeah, I do.
I want to fill it in.
Okay, watch this.
Wait, the edit is so fine.
they have no clue what they're getting they have no clue
what they're getting i would kind of i think i would go to a
store like this though like a a photography studio where
they edit your photo but you have no idea how they're gonna
edit it you know it seems kind of fun
okay mountain dew
it's a bit like a deco checky it is it is
okay save yeah okay he needs four by six nine of them what
was that and then one more for me oh my bad not the goku
lady scared me grab our envelopes there you go bud oh he
even paid me have you seen this boss
whoa oh gosh We really gotta get these lights fixed.
Who is this?
That's kind of...
CJ.
Who's CJ?
Holy posture.
Hello.
I'm releasing a new album.
Take my photo while I pose for an album cover.
Oh, sick.
Okay.
Oh, GTA.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Why am I so bad?
Oh, there we go.
It says stand on the X, but you really don't have to.
Okay.
Three, two, one, shoot!
Nice.
That was a great photo, I think.
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
Now how do we want to edit this?
We need, okay, first though, we need, like, the action
lines.
And maybe he's going Super Saiyan.
There's so many cars and stuff going out around.
It's a busy neighborhood, huh?
No wonder we're getting so much business.
I never thought a photography studio would be so...
Okay, we'll zoom out.
Oh, wait, that kind of ruined it, but that's okay.
Don't worry about it.
Bro looking tough.
He is tough.
He's the toughest you'll ever meet.
And then, no Super Saiyan.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's so good.
This might be my magnum opus.
There's so many.
I think I have rats or something.
This was tank.
Here.
Yeah.
Okay, wait.
I'm losing my mouse a little bit.
There we go.
Yeah.
Okay, now watch this.
This is where it's gonna get real.
This is where it gets real.
Hold on.
Hold.
Oh my god.
This is great.
You love the vision?
This is sick.
This is so sick.
Yeah!
Okay, well how many you want?
Three by four?
I think he should get more of these, honestly.
Gallo singing.
You are not even gonna believe.
He's just sent.
He has no clue.
so awesome he has no idea his life is about to be changed
it's funny i forget this is a horror game a little bit i
know i will be reminded when things get even more spooky but
come one come on any more customers oh oh oh no no
when I was like, one, come one, come all.
Oh, no, no, no.
No.
I need to get a photo taken that I can use for a job
application.
Oh, this guy gonna strangle me.
Hands in the air.
Hands in the...
I just heard him right in the public.
Bye.
I'm so scared.
Oh, You sucker!
Wait, maybe I should be locking this, huh?
Oh, wow.
Here, complexion is, uh...
This is like real... Oh, sorry.
My friends at school claim I do not show up in photos.
I need a photo as proof to them.
Oh, my camera.
Yeah, but there's just a random clown hiding in my
apartment, perhaps.
We'll get him with the broom.
I don't think we're supposed to be living here.
This is not really like a livable setup, no?
Vampire.
I want to be friends with her.
Oh, oh, oh my god, she's so hot.
Alright, ma'am, three, two, one.
Oh, she's, oh yeah.
Oh, she's feeling good.
She's feeling good.
Yes, queen, yes.
Oh, whoa.
I don't even want to do anything to her.
She reminds me of the goth lady from that hotel horror game
you played.
Yes, I know what you're talking about.
about the one where it was like the blurred faces right give
her wings maybe a cape we can make her a wait we can make
her like a legit vampire yeah
cool cloak don't worry I'm on it I'm on it oops
that's okay that's okay and then like a little like this but
the inside is red oh my eyes Oh wow, that's really, that's
really bright.
Oh gosh, wait, I might have made a mistake.
Oh my god.
Oh it's so bright.
Oh my god, it's so bright.
Okay, I don't want to look at it anymore.
Oh bleh, uh, yeah, she can go.
Uh, bleh.
Oh bleh.
Save.
How many do you want?
Landscape, 4 by 6.
4 by 6.
by six to start.
Ubleh.
Ma'am, I can prove to you that...
Oh, wait.
I gotta...
I can prove to you...
Gosh.
I can order envelopes.
Oh, yeah, we really did run out.
Thank you.
Okay, so I gotta order from the store.
Envelopes.
Yes.
Wait, how much money?
Oh, I have...
Wait!
Okay, background, soft box, frames!
Uble, uble, uble, uble.
Get some frames.
I think we should get the background first.
Hello, welcome.
Oh, oh my god.
You can order or you can pick up delivered orders from the
delivery pallet in the back alley.
Oh.
Um...
Uh...
Okay, he can't turn his head completely.
Um, one moment...
Oh, look at this!
It looks so good!
Yeah, no shirt, no shoes, no service, buddy.
How can I help you?
I miss my wife so much I want to take a photo for her.
If we reunite someday, I want to give it to her.
Oh no, he's hanging his head low.
Oh, no.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, come on.
You gotta really appeal to her.
Oh, landscape.
Okay, so it does say landscape.
Okay, here we go.
Oh, boy.
You gotta show her a little something.
I don't like where my...
You wanna know how I lost my shirt?
I don't like where my target is focusing on.
You never know what's going on in someone's life.
They could have the biggest smile on their face, but when
they walk, you'll really see how sad things are.
Yeah, he's just depressed.
Uble?
Guys, I gotta go to the little ghosty's room.
I'm afraid that I'm gonna get jump scared and pee and pee
myself, so...
I'll be right back.
I'm scared!
I'm back.
Everybody stay hydrated.
Everybody sing.
Hydrated, right?
Oh my goodness.
Welcome back, thank you!
Just draw over her.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, oh gosh, I'm gonna click on it.
Ah!
Oh!
What is it?
Something wrong with the photo?
No?
For a second, I thought you were someone else.
Lying can come back to haunt you.
No, no.
You don't want it anymore?
I should close the shop and get some sleep.
Ew, ew, ew, ew.
That spooked me.
I want to go home.
Yeah, me too.
Let's- Oh.
What?
Oh, um.
Uh.
Anyway.
Good night.
What did I miss?
Time to go.
to go home.
Okay, we're home.
Day two.
I would be sleeping with every single light on.
I'm not even kidding.
We missed a creepy lady.
My bad.
She jumped at me!
Oops.
No, she didn't.
Oh, what a lovely time of day.
Perfect to open my creepy store.
I hope we get lots of customers today.
Oh!
Oh.
Excuse me, sir.
I'm running a business here.
You literally dodged it.
Can't scare me if I'm not paying attention.
Don't ask questions.
Just listen.
I know what you saw last night.
The previous owner, your father, worked with you.
us now it's your turn take this key in this film role i'll
be back to collect the printed results don't mention me or
what we talk about to anyone we'll meet again soon
oh i got a key wait is it this ow Oh.
Oh.
Developing photo.
What the heck is that?
Interact with the cutting station until the film roll is
used up to produce the photos in negative form.
Okay.
Place the negative photos into the developer.
Stop bath and fix your solutions in order.
Then wait for the process to finish.
Hang the photos you take from the fixture on the drying rack
to dry.
So we got like the actual men in black coming in.
one strike you can collect the photos and put them in an
envelope oh
oh oops was that not supposed to take that oh she oh no oh
uh anyway uh excuse me oh uh wait okay so we put it in here
mannequin just wanted to say hi You took her heart.
I didn't mean to.
I thought it was a love note to me.
I thought it was a love note.
Oh, I saw that was a creepy baby.
I'm scared.
You guys, I just, I don't want to go get ice cream.
Can't tell what that one is.
Then we hang it up.
It's a creepy.
It's a walker.
Peace walker.
UFO, UFO!
Creepy baby?
Okay, that's done.
Oh, you.
Yeah, why do we have a mannequin?
Great question.
Maybe I'm so sorry.
I'm because she's really mad at me.
I'm really sorry.
One second, sir.
One second.
I'll be with you.
Like, so speedy.
So fast.
Oh, oops.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, this one?
Wait, this one.
I developed my first photo.
I got an achievement for it, but it's a creepy baby.
Okay.
UFO.
So feet?
What did I say?
Mito-chan?
Hi!
What do you guys like?
Going home.
any going home enjoyers out here one second sir one second
you've been so patient we just got a really demanding guy
you know oh top secret cool my favorite flavor depends i
guess we'll just leave this like how can i help you i need
to renew my id can you take a photo in the correct size sure
thing can do i is this you simulating you driving the car my
favorite i like i don't know sometimes it depends on if i'm
on a fruity mood or a creamy mood going home flavor hits
hard especially with gummy worms and oreos on top that's how
i get mine See, he is.
Portrait.
Oh, yeah.
Looking handsome there.
Buddy?
Yeah, he's got a confident stride and all.
Okie dokie.
Oh, creepy, creepy, creepy.
Hmm.
Maybe we should...
Make him a steering wheel.
I was going to say we could put the steering wheel.
But it looks like he's kind of riding a bike instead, no?
Kind of looks like he's riding a bike.
One second.
Sir, my craft takes a few moments.
I know that I was already late to your appointment.
But my craft really just, you know.
be struck by inspiration only orthochromatic black and white
film and photo paper is safe to develop in red lights most
film stocks are sensitive to red light and will get ruined
also i have like the door wide open like it's not even it's
not even a proper safe or like dark room does this look like
a bike from the front wait it should only have well it
should wait Now it's a tricycle.
That's fine.
It's a tricycle.
Hold on.
We can give him a little hat.
Like so.
And it's got some cool colors.
What's your favorite color, buddy?
I like blue.
Oh, yeah.
Me too.
We'll do some blue.
And we'll do some red.
Oh, yeah.
We'll do a little bit of yellow.
Uh-huh.
Um, um, wait.
I'm gonna fix this.
Oh, shoot.
I'm not fixing it.
Oh, no.
It's a cap.
I'm ready for kindergarten.
A lollipop?
We are the lollipop keys.
The lollipop keys.
It's a little not circular, but that's fine.
Don't worry about it.
A little melty?
No, no, no.
Oh yeah.
What do you want?
Oh, print.
Two by three.
Six of them.
Wow, that's a lot.
not enough paper okay good thing I can afford paper oh my
gosh wait that's terrifying was that it one second sir I'm
not properly stalked
almost soft locked for real though can this go there we go
okay cool cool cool start what What would I, what?
What would I do if I had run out?
For real, though.
How much money do I have?
Okay, 22 bucks.
Okay, okay, okay.
So we have to keep enough money for ink and paper for now.
And stuff.
Why do you lock the door?
Because there's a crazy clown on the loose.
Okay.
He was offering free candy, but is it really?
We don't know.
Ooh, yes, girl.
I took some photos for my New Year planner.
Can you develop them?
Oh, okay, yeah.
Oh, it's just the two of them?
Okay, nice.
Yeah, she's so sassy with it.
Yeah.
I'm not even scared of mannequins, really.
In a hole.
horror game.
I'm trying to think of like what would be, I don't know,
atmospheric horror is very spooky to me.
Manikins don't really scare me.
Clowns don't really scare me.
You know, but a jump scare will scare me, you know, if that
makes sense, right?
Oh yeah, girl.
She's living her best life.
Oh, I do still have something in my iron slot.
You're right.
Ah, thank you, thank you.
if it's a jumping clown that that might terrify me that
might that might be it
oh yeah the concerts oh the dollar bills dang girl what is
this oh my gosh it's so oh my god no stop please what did i
not oh that's why
uh i'm doing this all so wrong doing it all so wrong okay
okay okay all right all right and then throw that there just
for now okay okay okay okay
saw a trailer for a horror movie that had a jump scare in
the trailer felt downright unfair there was one like that
that like got a lot of people um oh my gosh it scared me
though i thought it someone's standing there um it was like
the i think it was called passengers or something the mom
movie oh wait did that did that one have the other mother or
whatever the other mommy fish fear me women fear me i walk
alone on this barren earth
come again what my mouse is very shapely Is this my papa?
When you start working for that guy, do you also get a
blurred face?
It does look like a bar of soap.
Alright.
Oh, a customer.
A customer!
Everybody look lively!
Look at this jolly guy.
The photos I take of myself look terrible.
Can you take a good one?
They could never look terrible with the amount of...
of confidence you have oh, oh,
vamp?
sorry.
bro, how did I turn out?
Does it look good?
I was gonna turn him into vamp.
but now you don't ever have the satisfaction of of You want
a good photo?
Go somewhere else!
Five copies of this.
I think you'll get mad.
I should have done it in black and white.
It's a save on ink even.
Yeah, I hope you like the photo.
Jerk.
You still paid me.
Yeah!
ink.
I'm even, I'm even deleting the photo.
I didn't mean it.
Ah!
Oh, that was a car.
I didn't mean it.
Power!
Oh, he's so mad!
Oh, shoot.
I'm mad at him.
It's gonna be behind me or something.
I didn't mean it.
Why does my power go out all the time?
Father, what kind of store have I inherited from you?
you it was you it surely wasn't this guy it was you oh my
god I freaking knew it are you leading me inside come on in
oh oh oh
Listen, kid, they say I need to put a profile on that
Zuckbook thing.
Take one for me.
Of course.
Zuckbook, that's what this is for, right?
Ooh, la la.
Oh, yes!
Yes!
This is going to turn out great, not like the last guy.
Also, it didn't let me delete the photo.
Hmm.
Slaying.
What should we do?
Oh my gosh, what a fabulous photo.
Oh yes.
I think turning him into a cat girl is perfect.
So kawaii, kawaii.
Clear, clear.
Kawainya!
I wish I had half the charm that guy has.
He meant only furs.
Not all of us can be so precious.
You know?
Meow.
Oh, meow.
He says, I'm a little meow, meow, meow.
Meow, meow.
I'm a little meow.
Here is my meow tail.
Meow, meow.
I'm a little meow.
Meow.
Meow, meow.
That's his meow meow song.
He sings at every party.
Every party.
He says, I'm a little meow, meow.
Meow, meow.
I want to go to in Photoshop.
Yes, I would make you the best thing ever.
The best photo of you.
Hold on.
I want to give him big pause.
Wait.
That's gross.
Never mind.
Delete it.
That's fine.
It's fine.
Save, save.
Now, how many of these do you want?
Just one?
It's a good one, but a good one.
One but a good one.
Yes, siri.
Thank you for the cash.
I may have a new business in my hands, binto.
Look.
If I'm ever done with V-Tubing, whenever that day comes,
I'll open up a photo studio.
One way less creepy than this.
You come in.
No, no, whatever I feel inspired to do.
Put it as your profile picture.
Your, send it, send it to your grandma.
Uh, uh, do anything, anything you'd like with it.
First the Zuck book.
Next he'll be a tic-tac sensation.
Meow, meow.
I am a journalist.
I have some news photos.
They need to be developed without showing anyone.
and do not call the police i don't even think i have a phone
to call the police i got wait you're a journalist no
suspicious journalism huh how'd you get these photos mr
journalist
i don't like this game guys i don't like this game anymore i
don't like this anymore I don't like this game anymore I
don't like this game anymore I don't
I'm a little meow I'm
turning though I'm turning the sound down for me not for you
guys though good luck oh you excuse me oh you turned off all
the way he's just my customer is standing here in the dark
ma'am please I'm so sorry ignore ignore the stinking
mannequin you get pranked I should have never touched her
heart.
Now, what are these photos?
I like the implication that he just watched it happen,
right?
Look at the booty on this girl, too.
I can't be mad at her.
I'm a little meow meow.
How did you get these photos now?
Let's see, what do we got here?
Oh, this is so close up.
What?
He has the best zoom in the world.
Telephoto lens.
Man, I kid you're not Nosferatu.
Find your own bit.
Exactly!
Look at this!
Okay.
How did you get this photo?
Hmm.
He tried real hard.
Yeah.
I think he did a great job.
What's this one?
It looks like a body, no?
This is so artistic.
Yes.
What's this one?
Okay.
Yeah, you're the journalist that took these.
You didn't put them on a timer or anything.
Nothing to make yourself feel so cool.
We sure don't ask questions, do we now?
We just...
Is this how my papa worked the shop, too?
With you as well?
Maybe he knew how to handle her.
I don't know how to handle a lady, clearly.
Journalists.
Yeah, the pay...
The pay's okay.
It keeps the light on sometimes.
The lights are a little finicky.
Oh.
Don't mind the lights!
Oh, hey, you're in the title screen!
Dear, I do not have any color photos.
Can you take a color photo of me?
A color photo.
It's 2026.
Journalist slash serial killer.
Okay.
Swap, slap, slap, slap, slap.
One photo coming right up.
I'm a little meow meow.
Are you okay?
Uh, I don't think I'm feeling very well.
Did we turn out that- did we?
Did we turn out that bad?
Take your take your take your.
Anytime it's too haunted, you take it and go.
I don't want it.
I don't know.
What are you?
Who is we?
You are not French.
Oh, gosh.
The Vatican scared me again.
Get out of here.
Take your freaky child, too.
Wee, wee.
Oh, I should close the shop and get some sleep.
Good night.
Good
night, everybody.
good night everybody don't wake me up don't do anything
freaky to me in the morning I don't want to see it I don't
want to hear about it I don't want to know about it
I said don't wake me up I said don't wake me up I said I
don't want to know about it I don't want to hear about it I
don't want to do anything about it I can recognize my
stinking yellow wallpaper I could see it oh my god
wake me oh I don't have my flashlight wait I don't have my
flashlight or anything I can't see anything.
Wait, I really can't see anything.
Uh.
Oh my gosh.
This is freaky.
Wake me up.
Wake me up inside.
I'm trying to find the light switch.
Hello?
Oh gosh.
Hey!
Wake me up inside.
Save me.
Oh, that's the guy, no, Mr. Bald.
The guy who gave me the photos?
He's arguing with somebody.
Am I, like, a little kid?
and I'm watching him have a conversation with my dad.
Oh, oh, oh.
John Hitman.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh!
You are so sweet.
Watching over me as I sleep.
Look at you.
Obsessed with me or something.
And everything okay in this store?
Yeah, we're fine.
my alarm trying to wake me up after five separate alarms
honestly they should invent that after like you snooze so
many amounts of times the alarm clock monster comes and gets
it no no time for play time this is serious business
everybody back to serious hello sir i'm here to pick up
those photos from the film roll i gave you yesterday is that
just yesterday
It's becoming clearer.
Not bad.
We can move on to the next stage.
We installed special cameras around the shop.
Check them from your computer during the shift.
It's becoming...
It's turned into an anomaly game.
If you spot something abnormal, go there, photograph it,
then transfer it to the PC and report it.
No mistakes.
We'll meet again soon.
When did you do this, by the way?
Oh.
Oh, hello.
I'm also a...
I'm a vampire?
Okay, that's not abnormal unless.
Okay.
Ooh, I don't like this.
I don't like this at all.
Oh, where is this?
Oh, I think this is the door.
Okay.
Oh, I don't like it.
Oh, gosh, okay.
Huge man!
Oh, I took some photos over the weekend and transferred them
to a USB drive.
Could I get one print of each?
Wow, USB.
Wow!
Print 4x6.
Oh, wait, did I do it?
Hold on.
Wait, I can't, I don't know, actually.
Did I print the second one?
Hold on, I think I'm stupid.
Wait, I think I'm stupid.
I'll just do this one.
Print.
4 by 6.
I think I got it.
I think I did.
One, two, three.
There we go.
You don't want your stick back?
Okay.
I got lost in the sauce for a second.
I think, um...
What's my printer like anyway?
We might want to order some...
Oh, we got ink.
We'll get...
We'll get envelope and paper.
And the...
No, I should save my money.
Anybody here?
Oh!
Hello, nurse!
Free stick!
Yeah, we got the USB!
one moment please
oh that guy you might still be standing out there you might
still be standing out there ink is 50 okay we'll just throw
all of these for now I wish I could check how much ink I
have and also how much paper I have but I want a photo of
the shh pose to be used on hospital What?
What does that mean?
Oh.
Shhh.
Sure.
Why though?
Okay.
I don't get it, but I respect it, I think.
Check the camera real quick again.
Oh!
Um, one moment.
One moment, please.
Oh!
What was he doing?
What was he doing in there?
By my bed!
Report it, report it.
I don't want to see it.
He's just...
ironing his clothes?
Oh, then he can go do that at his house.
Okay, we're working on this.
Good.
This evidence will do.
Awesome.
I'm about to turn her into Nimi Nightmare.
Okay, this is Nimi Nightmare from Memory, you guys.
Kumbakua!
Nimi from Nightmare.
Nimi nightmare from memory okay and let's give her little
ears as well
nimi from nimi nightmare yep and then she has is it on this
side i'm not sure that's her ribbon oops
um and then oh
shoot and we gotta accentuate the curves no no Not clear,
not clear.
Not clear, not clear.
Okay.
I think that's good.
Wait, I want to draw her apron too.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, wrong one.
Oh la la, hello nurse.
Oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah.
What about the name tag?
You're so right.
Right there.
Wait, maybe I can put it in.
Perfect.
I think that looks pretty good.
I think that looks pretty accurate.
Oh, and then, uh...
Oh,
I was writing cool in Japanese.
Oh my gosh, I'm such a weeaboo.
Come back.
Like I was writing it like this.
Like...
Okay.
Save.
How many you want?
She wants six of these.
Six, four by six.
You're gonna love it.
In fact, you shall look into getting bangs.
A little front fringe?
Yes, ma'am.
It would look great on you.
I could see why my father did this until whenever.
Until mysterious circumstances.
Konbaku.
Yeah, nice messy bob.
Everybody should get a messy bob, though.
The weeb in her is showing.
It doesn't stop showing, to be honest.
Camera check, you're so right.
One
second, huge man.
Okay, that's normal.
Oh, I hate that.
Anyway.
Err.
Good.
Wait.
smoke oh my god he is humongous humongous among oh golly i
don't want to go take a picture of that i'm so sorry i'm so
sorry i don't want to take a picture of this i really don't
i really don't they're trapped are you trapped under my bed
i wish you would stop being there
It was not meant for people.
Oh, report.
Get it out of here.
Get it.
Why is it taking so long to send?
Good, this evidence will do.
Awesome.
A girl I met online asked for a full body photo.
I bet she did.
Hope you can take it.
Do the limbo.
I sure hope I can too.
Oh my god.
Oh, wow.
Wow.
Can I just...
I...
I really...
I don't...
I go up to...
I don't even go up to his butt.
Okay.
This is it.
All right.
Smile.
Six foot versus 5-11.
I can't help...
So this is actually how it feels like for me every day, my
afterlife.
Dude, reminds me of what I felt like in the Winchester
House's attic and basement.
Wait, how tall are you, Dorko?
You know, when I went to the Winchester House and in the
attic and the basement, I didn't have to duck like, what?
Hmm.
You fit perfectly, didn't you?
Yes, we know.
Well, Sarah Winchester was about the same height as me, so,
um, so, honestly, the whole place feels really comfortable
for me.
Dorko's a tall fella!
One of my Oshis may be 90% legs, but this takes the cake.
This guy's gonna look awesome in his foot.
Maybe we can shrink him a little.
Hold on.
Wait.
I'm not trying to sabotage him.
Okay, this is a shoe.
And another shoe.
Right?
And then.
He could be taken down a notch.
He could get taken down a notch.
Oh, I made it really wobbly.
Not trying to sabotage.
No, no, no, no.
It's too tall!
It might freak her out!
You know?
I'm doing him a favor.
Oh, shoot.
Shoot.
Hold on.
Oh, my gosh.
My hand slipped for real.
I'm doing him a favor.
Doing him a favor.
Yes!
Um.
Good.
Save.
Uh, three, five, four, and three of them.
Oh.
Not enough paper.
One more.
I don't even know where to look up.
Paper.
This might be the end of my ankle.
Honestly, that's still quite tall.
What if she's a climber?
She wants the challenge.
Said who?
Said no one ever.
There you go, sir.
Oh, thank you very much.
Don't hit your head on the way out.
Uh, envelope box.
Do I have to take the garbage out?
Oh, wait.
Uh, let's check the cameras.
I wish...
Actually, I prefer checking them when someone's here.
Oh, gosh.
One second, sir.
Okay.
Why do they show up?
I am a vampire.
All right.
Nothing here.
One moment, sir.
I don't want to...
Okay.
Anyway.
Yes, how can I help you?
I found this film roll in my grandpa's keepsake box.
Could you print the photos?
Sure, but...
Is that the security camera?
I don't remember leaving it on.
What if Grandpa wants these to stay a secret?
Maybe you're the invisible man.
I could be.
Sussy photos of Grandpa.
If I ever were to find like a family, I don't know.
I would feel, especially if they were like locked away or
something, i would be like do i do i get these developed
like so far they look very normal but i think i would be
quite suspicious
hmm saucy yeah exactly saucy grandpa yeah these look normal
these look normal but they don't oh they won't always look
normal curiosity will get Get me?
Yeah, but you would never be able to return to being the
person that you were before you saw them.
Just keep that in mind.
What is this?
I don't know.
Oh.
You can see my photos and you can even see how far they're
developed or not.
That's so funny.
What's the two out of three here?
I just noticed it.
Do I have to get three, like, anomalies?
Everyone has a chain link fence.
Yeah, exactly.
Kitty!
Oh!
Good photos.
There you go.
Thank you.
Kitty, kitty, kitty.
Oh.
Yeah, look.
Oh, so cute, so cute, oh, so cute, so cute.
Do I have to get one more?
Okay.
Hello.
What is she doing?
What am I doing?
Did you see that?
Wait, see what?
What did I say?
Psst!
Hey, handsome.
Take a hot photo of me.
Me?
Points to self.
Handsome?
Oh.
Oh, grandma.
You can feel hot at any age, everybody.
Hot at any age.
Oh my gosh.
Stop doing that.
Sorry, I'm paranoid about this.
I don't know how many more we'll get before the day ends.
You know what I mean?
Okay, anyway.
Time to put her into the red dress.
Hugging them curves.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, oh, oops.
It's okay.
We can fix it in post.
We can Fix it in post?
Oh, yeah.
From Grandma with love.
We'll make it extra low cut even.
Oh, my gosh.
Sexy on fire.
On fire.
Sexy and on fire.
Like legitimately on fire.
So sexy and on fire.
So sexy and I'm fire, fire, fire.
Someone call an ambulance.
Apparently they saw the anomaly.
I also figured you'd do the red dress.
Wait, what was the anomaly?
Wait, did I not see it?
One moment, man, before I show you Really sexy photo.
There was a guy on the couch.
There was?
E!
One second!
Oh, he's gone.
Oh, wow!
This is not your therapy session, mister.
Report?
I should start getting the frame so I can print out my stuff
and like hanging out you know um print six copies thank you
guys yay we got the three out of three that we needed cool
not enough ink oh finally uh ink box oh wait okay okay i got
it i got it i know do the thing Zam granny, you are legit
smoking.
Someone call.
Oh my gosh, it's so bright.
Someone call for an ambulance.
Thank you.
Thanks for showing me the guy on the couch, guys.
I would have...
This is burn-on hot blood and cream.
Okay.
Let's order some frames.
We'll get some more paper, I guess, maybe.
I think I have enough envelopes.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, the light flickering gets me every time.
Oh my gosh.
Little, little, little.
Oh.
Back rooms, man.
One moment, please.
I gotta start hanging out.
at my stuff wait okay hold on brain box and uh paper box how
do i placement oh here we go
oh nice we gotta put some in the front of the shop so people
everybody can see oh yes oh yes don't worry about that the
trash will go out on tuesdays yeah lethal company guy lethal
company guy didn't i oh no we've accidentally we didn't
Okay, hold on.
Let's print out Nimee Nightmare.
Let's print out Little Meow Meow Two.
We'll do We'll do this guy.
And then we'll hold off on like another amazing one.
Okay.
Little meow meow, that could be you.
Kumbakua.
These are great.
I need you to take off your thing next time so I can
understand.
So I can understand what you're saying next time.
Oh my god.
What is this?
What's that?
I thought I heard something.
I'm sorry.
Is it because I took it your heart?
And I have to get pieces of the ladder.
I'm spooked.
Oh!
Am I dead?
Hey, YouTube.
Am I okay?
She looked away too long!
We're back, we're back.
Oops.
Sorry about that, guys.
Sorry about that.
I think it was YouTube, though.
My side seems totally fine.
Mint says something.
Hmm.
Is it YouTube or the background?
Backgrounds?
Is the backgrounds, yeah.
There's only...
Gosh!
Oh my gosh, there's only just the one, right?
Oh my gosh.
Oh, it doesn't like the...
Look at her eyebrows.
Golly.
She doesn't like camera.
So...
And I think that's my camera up there.
Running in slow motion.
Me running in a dream.
I think that's my camera up there.
So we have to get my camera.
What happens if it catches you?
I don't know.
I don't really want to find out.
I hope there's only just the one.
Oh my...
Hey!
Madam!
I'm watching you.
It became a horror game about Oshi Rage Quit.
I haven't Rage Quit yet.
Okay, I'm going.
I'm searching for the other pieces.
Hey.
I'm so not good at these types of things.
Uh...
Where'd it go?
Hey!
Stay back!
Stay back, you wench!
I don't...
It's kind of fast, too.
Stay back!
We need...
I'm like just hugging the walls right now, hoping I see it.
Oh, there's something there, though.
Uh...
Maybe I need to get this first, though.
Oh my gosh.
Can there please be?
If you guys see anything, just yell.
If you're like, there's a piece of the...
Piece of the ladder!
I haven't not seen one yet, though.
Oh!
I lied.
Hey!
How am I supposed to grab it?
Wait, why am I frozen?
Maybe it is me.
Whoa!
That was freaky.
We're back to normal?
I can't crouch.
Stop it.
Ma'am?
I'm gonna need you to...
That was so close.
Holy cow.
That was so stinking close.
Maybe we need to do a bigger loop.
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm so not good at these things.
Should be like right here.
Actually, I don't know.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
We got it?
I just...
Oh.
All right.
Stuck on something?
I can't turn around to look.
Oh, that's where I'm stuck.
Little lady.
Little lady, leave me alone.
At least it's just one.
I say there might be more.
Eventually.
There's another one!
Oh my gosh!
Oh, sheesh.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
The evil segment for real.
Do you think it's back in here?
Again?
Uh.
I'm just gonna stay in the middle and like kind of use my
peripherals.
This actually is a good spot.
Um.
I do have a flashlight but it's rinky dink unfortunately.
I feel like I walked all through this area Maybe it's
Like I feel like I really explore No Maybe it's on this side
Cause we
Oh my gosh You think it's at the start How many pieces are
left?
It looked like just one Oh my god Lady Lady Liddy.
Wasn't there a room you noticed?
There was a hallway down that way.
I had her in such a good spot before too.
Being here, yeah.
You should be stomping all over.
Oh, this is an evil segment.
Evil, evil.
Maybe it is over here.
Walking backwards, walking backwards.
Well, maybe like in here or something, right?
Oh!
Oh, yeah, awesome, awesome, awesome, awesome, okay, okay,
okay.
Very good, very good.
It is evil a little bit, but the area is actually not quite
so big or confusing, so that's pretty nice.
I saw her cutting through the wall.
How do I do this now?
Wait.
Oh my gosh, lady.
Lady!
Oh my gosh.
Oh,
it's done though.
It's done.
Okay, okay.
Oh.
Second.
Hey.
I don't know if I can grab it in time.
Okay.
It's temporary.
I don't know if that was...
If that...
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
What the hell?
Oh, no!
I thought this was the end!
She's definitely getting closer.
Okay, hold on.
Okay.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
run run run run run maybe is it one of these like where you
take a photo and then you of you oh shoot oh oh shoot how am
I supposed to remember this wait how am I supposed to
remember this oh
gosh uh the left side
If I'm looking at the photo, but I'm looking at her, it
still counts, right?
Uh, left.
Oh my god, there's no way I'm going to remember this at all!
Oh my gosh.
Okay, hold on.
Taking a photo with my phone.
Can guide yourself with the squares?
How?
Down.
Okay, that does work.
Here?
Wait.
Thank you for the raid!
Sorry, hold on.
I'm so lost.
I'm trying to concentrate.
Thank you so much.
Thank you!
Wait, hold on.
I'm pulling out my trusty phone.
I don't know how far over I am.
Take more photos of the maze.
Wait, you're so smart.
Drop.
Okay, hold on.
Take another photo.
Reset her.
View photo.
Okay, so I do turn here.
Okay.
Thank you, Lance!
Thank you!
Thank you guys so much!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Death Pigeon, thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
So here.
Here.
here don't don't don't they don't oh uh shoot one uh one two
up one and
then over one two my
god we made it back wait
for my photos whoa there really happened um just get rid of
this get rid of this Oh my gosh.
Are they on here too?
No new photos.
Wait, oh, wait.
We did get all the anomalies we needed to get, so that's
good.
Holy cow.
You would not believe the time I had.
Oh, I forgot to close this door.
Little Missy.
Oh, I even missed the flickering light.
guy a word please oh hello no no no please God no please
please please okay these are actually segments that scare me
no no no no no no no no
no no what are we doing now oh my gosh 10 seconds of
relaxation i just oh oh what even what even did they want me
to do what do they want me to do oh gosh okay
give us a breather all right i must be brave What is this?
Oh.
Oh, why?
Oh, guy?
Oh, what was that?
What was that?
Is there something?
I'm like watching.
I'm watching the game through OBS.
Oh, wait, no.
This is the door I went through.
It's BT.
I like the way I flash.
I hear something.
Oh!
What
do you hear?
Someone's talking.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
What am I supposed to do, though?
Yeah, no flashlight.
Oh, look.
Gosh, I don't even know where I'm going.
I'm looking.
Ah.
I'm so lost.
Okay, that's that.
So it's this way.
Maybe I need to go back.
Oh.
It's so scary.
Ah, I don't like it.
I can't tell at all.
What do they want me to do?
Photograph the vent.
Did I not?
I'm pretty sure I did.
Oh, oh.
There it is.
Oh, oh, what the heck?
Oh.
I vented.
Sorry for the flash, though, guys.
I know these kind of segments can be not so great on the
eyes.
Is that Mr. Bald?
Wait.
Did I go the wrong way?
Oh,
day four.
Wait, where's my mannequin?
Oh.
seizure I'm sorry blame the game not me where's my mannequin
where's my little lady at little lady you back in here
where's my little lady yeah oh my gosh oh serious time
serious time serious time fun time over your reports are
going well keep it up new photos came in print them like
last time i'll be back tomorrow to collect them your daily
quota has increased so don't forget to check the cameras
often yes sir i'm gonna why why would my papa not tell me
about this why would he not tell me about this i'm glad he
flips the sign back over when he leaves You know?
Oh.
A customer.
One minute, sir.
One moment, please.
Yeah, very considerate.
Very considerate for all that he's...
The hell that he's putting me through.
Childish centipede.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you, thank you very much.
Thank you, thank you so much.
Oh yeah.
This is what, this is, this is all your research.
Look at this.
Who took this photo?
What edgelord?
What edgelord is, are ta- You?
Mr. What the heck is even that?
Who is taking these photos?
oh wow wait is that the clown from outside you think one
moment sir one moment spooky none oh my gosh oh wow i'm so
frightened abstract art is this your evidence is this your
evidence of the paranormal i got your evidence right here
I'm holding up my fist, but you can't tell.
My man, take a charismatic photo of me and let our
reputation grow.
Cool.
Something's growing.
Me, Amonage Lord.
Been off topic.
Forgot to mention yesterday, but has anyone told Minto that
the Dokiman Tojin been in the popular section of a certain
number website since yesterday the one that it's quite funny
actually Doki like sent me a message and was like hey I want
you to sign something for me you'll have no idea what it is
oh wait where's my photo oh there it is and so
I did I almost, I took my own photo actually, and I was
gonna post it first, because I was like, you asked me to
sign this.
You asked me to do the hard labor.
I should have the credit for, I should have the credit for,
for, for, for it all.
But, but she, I let her, I let her have it.
I wouldn't be stolen valor.
Doki lied to us.
Oh, wait.
What was the story?
Wait, was there something I was supposed to go along with?
Oh, shoot.
Wait, I don't know.
What am I supposed to do?
Wait, I'm going to give this guy like a mega pack.
This is what six packs look like.
It kind of looks like an alien.
It kind of looks like a little alien that's like...
What does a...
what does a six pack look like wait oh wait i know what they
look like hold on
i know i know they're boxes they're boxes oh oops
yes yes
yeah king's hawaiian rules don't say that i'm hungry i'm
hungry
Let our reputation grow, mister.
Let our reputation grow.
And this thing is saying, you're welcome.
We got the Drake special.
What's that?
I don't like how that came out.
It's fine.
Actually, the way it looks exactly right now is perfect.
It's perfect.
Look up Drake's abs.
I don't know if I want to look of that.
Drake had a fake six-pack.
Drake's abs.
Huh?
Oh.
Bro thought he was fooling.
No, he didn't think he was fooling us at all.
Oh, oh, I thought you meant the guy that's talked about the
Drake special.
No, oh, wow.
Wow.
Oh my gosh.
Why would you do that?
Everyone's just gonna laugh at you.
I would rather be like 500 pounds than fake a six pack.
Like.
That's just...
Oh, wow.
Wow.
Okay.
Now I feel gross with this picture.
I don't want it anymore.
I didn't want it anymore to begin with, but 2x3, just one of
them.
Ah!
I forgot he was there!
He scared me.
He probably startled me more than anything in this game.
I went to go pick up an envelope.
There you go, buddy.
Give me the cash.
All right, let's check the cameras.
Okay.
What is a pinata?
Wait, what is it?
Oh.
Oh, no, he's not there.
Hello?
My ritual!
Why do they always come back to get me?
Look at the goats!
They really do...
Wait, it's not here though.
Wait, did I take the wrong place?
Wait, but he wasn't...
Wait.
Do I still report it?
Oh my gosh, my sick Victorian child.
But I...
I was too late!
What?
Uh-oh.
Wait, that shouldn't be?
Oh my gosh, now I need four!
Maybe there's another one?
One moment, one moment, I have a spooky thing to grab!
Uh-oh.
Oh my gosh.
I don't want to get jump scared.
Do you think this will work?
Um...
Please say yes.
No!
What is this?
Don't send me pointless reports!
I have to go more inside.
One second.
One second, my poor Victorian child.
It demands some privacy.
Keep getting the door!
I have to do it again.
Oh
my goodness!
Wow, that's quite the...
That's quite the body in my shower.
Thank you.
All right.
Oh, no.
Am I going to miss one because I missed the goat?
My goat.
I missed my goat.
Oh, geez.
I've never had a photo taken before.
I'm curious.
He really is a sick Victorian child.
This will be my first.
And your last.
Just stand in there.
He's kind of freaking me out.
Maybe it was a wrong angle.
For the goal?
But he's gone now.
He's gone from the video too.
Okay.
I'm not really feeling much inspiration from this guy.
He just...
It's just standing, staring at me.
Why is he so scrunched up?
I don't know.
Look.
Look, buddy.
I got a lot to do.
I'm just going to send you on your way.
Eight copies?
Okay.
Do I have ink, envelope, and paper?
Okay, I'll need more soon.
How about a hat?
I guess he could have used a hat, huh?
I'm a very busy ghost.
and also a little frightened.
There you go.
Thank you.
Let's grab some more let's grab some more ink.
I can't believe I missed it.
I'm so mad about it.
Okay.
Suddenly anomaly game.
What is that?
There's something in the trash!
I don't have time.
My store is full of freaks.
What's wrong with this town?
Oh my gosh.
Oh, actually it kind of looks like a grim fandangle.
Why do you close your eyes?
What about jumps at me?
I don't know.
Okay, good.
We got... How many do I need more?
Okay, two more, two more.
Yes?
I worked with your father before.
I hope you're as good as he was.
I need some documents...
document prints.
Can you print them from this USB?
Oh, I grabbed it.
He's hacking my computer!
What are you uploading?
You mother freaker.
Oh my god.
I bet I bet this is his truck.
I bet this is his truck.
Officer!
Where were you?
What is this?
Oh my god.
Wait is that my dad?
He got men in black for real!
Wait!
Maybe the guy was trying to help.
Maybe the guy, maybe he didn't actually hack.
Maybe he was trying to like warn.
Whoa.
Why is that door closed?
Wait, why is my bathroom door closed?
Somebody's in my bathroom!
I must go take a photo of the man on my toilet.
Um, excuse me!
Hey,
can't you see the doors closed?
Wait, what?
I thought this was a public restroom.
Anyway, I'm done already, thanks.
We must take a picture of the perpetrator!
Officer!
Officer, do something!
Oh, man.
I need to move.
I need to...
I need to go into the woods.
witness protection program stat.
Oh, man.
I give up.
This neighborhood safety is my job.
How are things going?
I don't feel safe.
Glad to hear there's no trouble.
I'm being silenced.
I need a photo taken for the new police posters.
What a stride on this guy.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh.
You walked all tough, but you stand like a What is this?
He's all like, you're standing all polite like, please,
please take my photo.
Please.
I just want to look good for my team.
Please, can you take a good one from a good angle, please?
Can I please get a good angle on myself so I can look really
tough and cool for my, for my pals back at the station?
I'm just a measly little officer.
I just really want
Can you get one that makes me look really tough and awesome?
My mom says I look so tough and cool.
She's gonna really love this one.
Yeah, she's really gonna love it.
Two photos.
Wait.
What's the second photo?
Oh, this guy.
I couldn't wait.
I didn't even do my job right.
I took a picture of his back of his head.
I couldn't even get it now what I can't show this to anybody
and say this guy was pooping in my toilet nobody would know
who it is
this is as good as a big foot photo oh my gosh if I report
it we could try
please please oh no it was it was useless we're gonna go
back to our roots remember the first photo i think we did
was really like moe cute and i forgot to save it this is
this is our second chance this
is our second we've been granted a second chance of making
the most moe kawaii photo
that we could make for this dearest officer moe blob eyes
have you seen this back
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, I'm just a wee, wee, wee, wee little
officer.
Oh, no, oh, my God.
Oh, it's a boob.
Hold on, wait, I have a good idea.
Let's do, like, um...
Let's do, like, a tokimeki moment with red hair.
Watch this.
Blowing in the water.
wind and
then like sakura blossoms oh this is a real anime moment
here they're blowing in the wind as well yeah and well now
i'm gonna fix his fix this a little bit oh oops did the
wrong one that's okay
Yes.
And I'll fill it in a little bit more.
Oh wait, I might ruin it.
That's okay though.
He looks like an apple.
He looks like a big freaking apple.
He looks like...
When will we get an English release of Tokimeki Memorial?
I don't know.
Ask Steiner to translate it.
Please.
Please go out with me, Senpai.
I'm just a little officer.
All I want to do is follow the wall.
Can't unsee the apple.
Yeah.
There we go.
A little less apple.
Oh, wait!
How could I forget?
You're amazing.
Seifuku.
We'll do blue.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Yes, yes.
It's a little backwards looking right now, but it'll come
out.
Don't worry, don't worry.
Hold on.
It's a little funky looking right now, but we'll fix it.
We'll fix it.
We get the lines.
Whoops.
We'll fix up the cherry blossoms that I covered up.
They're going in front of him.
It's dramatic.
It's depth.
This is your masterpiece.
Finally, good apple.
Plays bad apple in reverse.
Oh, wait.
Yeah.
One second.
okay every month i get like a notification that's like your
card has been used outside of the outside of the united
states and i get scared every time and i'm like my card got
stolen and i remember i'm paying for idols i have like
there's like a idol fan club that i signed up for you know
and i'm like oh yeah it's just the idol stealing my money
okay this is good i think this is good Alright, how many are
we doing?
Four by six, we're doing four of them.
I, honestly, I forgot how he looked.
I forgot how he looked.
There you go.
If you need anything, I'll be on duty at the corner all
night.
Just step out and call for me.
Okay.
I need you right now.
Sir!
Don't leave me.
like be not at the corner can you be right outside my door
please please i'm scared oh is that maxwell excuse me sir
swagger oh my gosh wait i think it's maxwell
kitty Oh my god,
I was right!
I don't want to report him.
He's my buddy.
Okay.
Yes, how can I help you?
I took some photos for a house I'm selling.
Could I get prints of them?
Sure thing, sir.
Oh, that's a fixer-upper.
Okay.
Uh...
Two...
Shoot.
I'm scared to go outside.
That's why I haven't taken the trash out.
Oh, wow.
Let's grab some more envelopes.
We'll grab some more paper.
We'll grab some more ink.
We'll grab some more frames.
Oh, the soft lights.
Yeah.
Wait, I want to see.
Oh!
We're looking It's so professional!
Oh my god.
These picks should be reported.
No, it's just a...
It's just, you know...
Really, you know.
Like I said, a fixer-upper, a fixer-upper.
Okay, so we're at 3 out of 4.
Call for help!
E!
Help!
Man, we saw something.
We saw someone running in the back alley.
I think he bolted when he saw us.
You see him safe for now.
Still, don't forget to lock your door.
Good thing I had the door locked.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, but my stuff is out there.
What was it?
I think I should close the shop and get some sleep.
I think we should...
We should...
Oh no.
I didn't get out the anomalies.
Wait, wait.
Can I still get one?
Oh, no.
No, because I missed the goat.
He's gonna get mad at me.
What if he kills me?
I don't want to go out.
I don't want to be out here.
It's gonna be so he's gonna yell at me.
Frames.
We got five more frames.
We can print some more, let's see, placement.
Oh, there we go.
All right.
Very nice.
Envelopes, paper, ink.
All right, let's print a few more things.
We might die, so yeah, we could put Maxwell on the wall.
Let's put him.
Let's print this one.
Beautiful.
Uh, have you seen this person?
Wait, hopefully we can write that.
Wanted.
For.
For Duki.
Sad Duki.
Okay.
Save.
Print.
What other ones do we want?
Not any of the scary stuff.
I think I put sexy lady.
Oh, wait.
We'll have to do some more.
All right, this guy can go behind the, you know, Maxwell
with the other cats.
It's so dark.
Did you clean the toilet?
I don't think there's a way, too.
It doesn't give me an option.
Yeah.
I can't.
That sucks.
Good night.
Good night, world.
How many days are there, I wonder?
Oh.
It's a dream again.
It's a dream.
I need a screwdriver.
It's a lot of toilet paper.
Okay.
That reminds me.
I have to get toilet paper.
I think of hours.
Oh, that's it.
Oh, okay.
I do have to hold it.
Alright.
I think I'm out of toilet paper.
Yeah, we're venting again.
This is just what I did as a kid, I guess.
Oh, it's nice and clear now.
What did you do to my dad?
why did you flash him why did you flash my dad why am I a
kid in the vents and
we That was freaky.
Is it?
Oh, maybe he did that because he was mad that I didn't get
all of the...
All the anomalies.
I'm really sorry, Mr. I tried.
There was an attempt.
He's gonna get mad that...
He's gonna get mad that, uh...
so disgusting also.
Oh, let's open up.
Open shop, baby!
It's a wonderful time of the morning or evening.
I pooped in that toilet!
No, no, no, no, no.
There's no way I could forget this back.
Oh, shoot.
Mr. Mr. I'm sorry, I'm sorry!
I'm here to pick up the photos from the film roll I gave you
yesterday.
No, no.
Great.
You're even better at this than your father.
Either way, today is your last chance.
I want you to fill your anomaly quota.
If you succeed today, you'll be rewarded.
My last chance.
He's going to kill me for real.
Pop, pop, his face is totally fine now.
It's totally unblurt.
I forgot about that.
Hello, customers.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
chattiest Maximus.
You've got what you need.
Let's get this done.
Oh, wait.
Do I see anything?
I don't.
I really wonder where the mannequin went, though.
Oh.
Sir, no shoes?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, wait.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
I hope I got a good one.
I really wanted him mid-action.
That was impressive.
That was quite impressive.
So we still need to get four today.
There he is.
And also me.
Invisible.
For some reason.
Okay, I don't see anything.
Oh, that's right.
That was good in here.
I don't feel like it's so good.
Oh.
I'm not really feeling it.
Can we even improve on perfection?
Give him wings.
Yeah, I was thinking that too.
Maybe, like, some sort of...
Wait, he kind of looks like he's petting a dog, maybe.
Okay.
Watch this.
Kind of looks like he's petting the dog.
Oh, watch this.
Oh, I forgot I could zoom in on these.
Dog.
Card bark?
No.
That's a dog.
He's petting the dog.
He loves this dog.
The dog loves him.
Ah.
And, uh, wait.
We'll do a little.
Oh, oh.
Wait, what else do dogs have?
Wait, I have a tail.
Oh, a collar!
Yeah, that's good, that's good.
Oh, yeah, that brings it to life.
Yeah.
Don't say that!
Don't go, Edward.
Edward.
Tongue, tongue, that's good, that's good.
Don't say that about him.
Oh, he's petting the dog.
He do be petting that dog.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, what if I change it to Scooby-Doo color?
And this can be shaggy!
This can be shaggy.
This is Scooby-Doo and shaggy.
There's so much brown.
There, we gave him his clothes.
Oh, sorry, I didn't see who raided me.
Hello, thank you.
Thank you, welcome in, welcome in.
You guys came in at a least way less stressful time than the
last group, which was during the back rooms.
That was frightening.
Raggy.
Yay!
Save.
It ended up working out.
Okay, print.
You just once won?
Wow, what a child.
Not even wasting my ink.
Shaggy after removing his limiters.
I can't seem to thank you!
Nesting glitch case, thank you.
Oh, okay.
All right, let's check the cams, check the cams.
All right.
Usually it's like in between.
I can still hear his VGM, it's awesome.
It's like in between each...
Oh, it sounds so like...
I'm gonna say it sounds so quiet.
Um...
I think that's our anomaly.
Wait, that was really freaky.
Oh, it's like a hand or something coming out.
Whoa!
Freaky.
Oh.
Oh, it's this guy again!
Leave me alone.
Giving you a hand.
Actually, it looks like he's giving me a thumbs up, no?
I think he really enjoys the job that I'm doing.
Thank you.
Alright, that's our first one.
Do you think I missed one then?
Oh, shoot.
I took photos of my pet.
Could I get a large print of each one?
Absolutely.
How pet we talk...
Oh.
Wow.
Is this legal?
Or...
Where are you storing that guy?
I don't know if that's allowed.
There you go, buddy.
Wait, what just happened?
Oh.
All right.
Check the cams.
I want to get our reward.
I just heard something.
What is that?
You guys hear that?
Oh!
It's the globe.
Span.
It's a cat?
Wait, how'd you guys see that?
Wait, is it really?
Is it Maxwellian?
Wait, oh wait, I already took the photo.
That's right.
Oh my god, baby!
Baby, baby!
I'm glad there's some spooky anomalies and then there's ones
like these.
That's good.
Kitty!
Oh, hey there, bro.
Hey, my guy.
People say you're really good at this.
Prove it.
I don't have to prove anything to anybody.
He wants eight of his own picture.
Oh, okay, buddy.
Looking real fly over there.
Sure thing.
I've got a reputation.
I saw it as like the best photographer in town.
Johnny Bravo.
That's a great one.
Wait, that's great.
Hey, mama.
Wait, actually, don't remember how it goes.
I don't remember how Johnny Bravo goes.
Hey, mama.
Oh, it's so quiet now without our Chad's music.
So sad.
I'll miss him.
Close enough.
All I did was...
All I said was...
BOW!
There's a black shirt and like some jeans, right?
It's got jeans on, but we'll make sure.
make them more Johnny Bravo-ish.
Oh, hey, mama.
Hey, mama.
Oh, yeah.
Whoa, mama.
His glasses are a little askew, but we don't mind it.
We don't mind it.
It's a totally different person.
It doesn't even look like you are you are you are you are
changed you are changed into you i cast upon you
transformation into johnny bravo whoo uh you want eight of
these that's insane you're kind of insane for that
oh he was wearing glasses i didn't even need to give a buddy
oh mine are better anyway it's fine
Wait, give a customer an incorrect order.
Oh, I forgot to give...
Wait, I can't believe it.
You were right.
You're amazing.
Wait a second.
I thought you worked alone.
Who's that behind you?
Oh, why, sir?
That's the...
That's the person...
That's the shitter of my toilet.
Excuse me!
He didn't pay!
Oh.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
And I did such good work on him!
Okay, let's check the cam.
Oh, come on!
Oh, hello.
Oh, geez.
This is the guy that tried to literally break into my...
into my store... into my house.
May I remind you, this is also my house.
Is
it suspicious that I have a picture of the missing guy as my
wallpaper?
That was freaky.
That was pretty freaky.
Nah, okay, good.
And that is the exact same version of the one that's on the
missing photo.
Alright.
Hello.
I've tried plugging this into my computer, but I couldn't
see the photos inside.
Can you fix it?
Okay, we have three out of four.
You plug this.
This.
Into your computer.
Oh no, another hack.
It better not be.
That guy was crazy.
We're plugging in the film.
I am there.
Look at, she's just smiling.
She knows nothing of the world.
What do you be taking pictures of?
Mamacita.
What are we doing?
I always thought, like, developing film was really kind of
crazy.
You just willingly, I mean, like, unless you know how to do
it yourself and you have your own studio and everything,
like, you just allow a person to see your personal photos.
It feels so kind of invasive.
Like, it's...
Wasn't there a Robin Williams movie about it?
I never actually watched it.
How he, like, kind of gets obsessed with people over their
photos.
Did you lock the back door?
I did, I did.
I'm pretty sure.
I'd like to know how and where she plugged in, right?
What are these?
Oh, they're like...
Oh, whoa, wow, the exposure.
Madame.
I think whoever took these photos you need a refund
The one where he talks about Evangelion Wait is that the
same one?
No kidding It is That's hilarious Oh my gosh the picking up
the order of operations for picking up the photos versus
envelope is so frustrating One part in Ava figure appears
Wait that's crazy There There you go.
Yes, sweet cash, sweet cash.
What do we need?
We have ink.
I think we're almost out of ink, actually.
I'm scared.
Hello?
Oh.
Okay, now we check, now we check.
now we check now we oh oh my god is that that lady's
freaking baby jumping on my bed hi one moment i have a
freaking baby the one that lunged at me
did she do it again this is why i close my eyes this is why
i close my eyes when i take the photos
I understand now, yeah.
Oh my god, that's so funny.
That's so funny.
Do you believe in fate, Neo?
I need a photo.
I can immortalize.
Dang.
Wait, am I the matrix?
Oh, grandma.
There you go.
It was so scary.
I think I've nearly cried a few times.
No!
Pizza net!
Pizza mess.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
We're immortalizing grandma.
Oh, I forgot I took this one.
Took some creepo shots.
Oh!
Does this count as an anomaly?
I already got four out of four, but...
Okay, sure.
We're just gonna...
immortalize.
Yep.
Yes, ma'am.
Oh, no!
It's the wrong guy.
Wait, I just realized, sorry, I'm in the middle of the
screen.
Oh my god.
Would you like Johnny Bravo?
Who the heck is this?
Wait, I need this.
I gotta throw these away.
Bye grandma!
The death card.
It represents the end of something or the beginning of
something else.
Free- oh she was staring at me when she was leaving.
Creepy, creepy, creepy, creepy.
This game is so creepy.
It's so funny and so creepy at the same time.
Ugh.
I should close shop.
Yeah, I should.
Oh, my gosh.
That was our last chance to get, like, an anomaly.
That's crazy.
Good night, world.
Wait.
Oh.
Did I hurt the door?
The jingle.
Oh.
Someone came in.
A robber.
No, no.
They took all my...
I just left everything open.
You ever do that when you fall asleep with your computer on?
And sometimes I'll like...
If I'm so tired after a stream, I will just like fall
asleep...
Or I'll just like leave my computer.
And then the next day I come back and I have like the live
stream tab still open.
I have my camera on.
And like...
VTube studio.
Everything open.
like hello mister we're glad you didn't betray our trust
we'll be working together a lot more and as promised we're
going to reward oh we're going to your reward now don't let
what you see frighten you we did what had to be done for
this world what
do you mean oh oh oh oh i'm going to I'm going to prison!
Yes, sir.
Your mosaic.
Your mosaic doesn't work very well up close.
If I kiss you, will your mosaic disappear?
What am I looking at?
SCP?
Wee!
Oh!
Papa!
What have they done to you?
Take me instead.
Dad?
Welcome to the team.
That's me!
Ah!
Cinema!
Oh my gosh!
Family matters, earn your reward!
Yeah!
I can see how there would be an endless mode of this now.
Oh, oh, oh, my failed attempts.
Trying to get the guy in the shower.
Oh my wow!
Oh, shaggy and scoops.
Maxwell.
I wonder what happens if you...
Um...
I wonder what happens if you don't do the anomalies then.
If you don't report them.
Hmm.
And she never took out the trash.
I never will.
If I continue...
can we get another different ending probably got mind wiped
maybe let's see hold on wait day five was what day so if I
don't do any I don't really necessarily want to go through
the whole thing again but maybe I can speed run it a little
bit maybe we can speed run What happened to the mannequin?
Really, she got left in the back rooms for real.
It was day five.
Okay, okay.
So let's just not do any of the anomalies.
Let's speed run through everything.
We'll just print out whatever people want.
And yeah, we just won't edit the photos or anything.
Oh.
Okay, yeah, he said do everything right today and we'll give
you what you want or we'll give you a reward.
See ya.
See ya, sir.
so we won't do any oh it's gone the poo is gone oh my god oh
my god oh the chad's here comes the chad yes sir
she flushed all right let's do this oh landscape's open
we'll just do like the bare minimum to zoom through it i'm
quite hungry actually so i do want to all right you print
four by six one
there you go see ya my background is gone too
no well we can reset it we can redo it is that airs oh Oh my
gosh, that scared me again.
Look out, Minke, he's gonna mega bonk!
I keep grabbing the camera first.
Oh, yes, your pet.
Your pet.
Mew, mew, mew, mew, mew, mew, mew, mew, mew, mew, mew, mew.
Mew.
Miao, miao, miao, miao, miao, miao, miao.
Dozo, thank you.
Oh, I think it's, like, getting mad.
I keep hearing, like, a...
So I think it's getting mad that I...
Wait!
Now it's just a picture of this guy!
There's no...
There's no writing!
Wait!
Everything is just people!
No, wait.
This is creepy.
It's all just people.
It's just people.
My editing is still on the computer, but the...
prints are gone okay the cat is spinning
yeah let's see if you're really as good in this blah blah
blah blah blah this guy wants eight pictures you're such a
scammer you're such a scammer also it's funny because he
scams you but i gave him the wrong order so like wait i
wonder are our photos of these guys is johnny bravo still
here No, okay.
Oh, wait.
Oh, my bad.
Print.
Three by four, eight of them.
Eight.
Okay.
I will give him the right order, though.
Evil Johnny Bravo.
Maybe he scams because of the wrong order.
Oh, maybe.
Five, six.
The next number.
And eight.
Dojo.
I can't believe it.
They were right.
You're amazing.
Oh, yeah.
Who's behind you?
You.
You say...
Help!
This guy.
You can stop him.
How?
Oh,
yeah, is this a lady that doesn't know how to...
Oh, wow, this is still open.
That's so funny.
Yes, I got you, lady.
I got you.
Oh, it's giving me a tutorial.
It's crazy.
Hot dog indeed.
Hot diggity dog.
Somewhat fitting.
I just got July's checkie today.
Masterpiece.
Oh, thank you.
Wait, that's so funny.
Wait.
July?
June?
I think it's a little behind.
Sorry, we are like, we are a little behind because of all
the events that's been going on with the Densetsu Patreon.
We have been a little behind.
Take a picture of the event.
No, no, we're going for the ending.
We're going for a different ending.
We're going for the ending where we don't do the anomalies.
And so the guy gets mad at us.
I want to see what happens.
I guess I'm guessing we probably only get like flashbanged
is my hypothesis.
But you probably is just like you're you're bad and and
frigiddy, frigiddy beam.
But yeah.
Ducky, ducky.
Thank you.
Wonder anything else I can buy.
Nothing else.
I don't want to reprint everything.
Wait, I could just brush?
Oh my gosh, it's just paint!
Oh, make your first edit in the paint app.
Help!
Probably get thrown in the cell too.
Yeah, yeah.
He does say that we're better than my dad.
Oh, it's the scary grandma.
She was the last one, no?
I hear that.
You're the stupid...
You're the dumb doll jumping on the couch or on my bed.
One little monkey jumping on the bed.
Alright, grandma, I really don't have all day.
I'm hungry.
Yeah, it's the witch lady.
I believe she was the last one.
What are these?
What is this?
View photo.
It won't let me view it?
What is this?
I don't know.
Alright.
It's creepy.
What was the backroom photos?
Alright, grandma.
Come on.
Grandma.
Grandma, I don't got all day for you, grandma.
It does kind of mortuary assistant vibes.
little bit, right?
They get the atmosphere right, I feel.
Again, it's a little spooky, or rather a little funny, quite
spooky.
Thank you.
I think the Mortuary Assistant takes itself a little bit
more seriously than this game, but it is quite similar, I
feel.
Oh, she's looking at me.
There's a it's a little uh uh i think they get the vibes
right in this game for sure yeah mortuary assistant scares
the heck out of me okay all right let's see what happens
today
i didn't click the bed this nobody was there oh my god
that's creepy i'm gonna go to sleep with this baby jumping
on me all right good morning me too all right let's see what
happens he's so disappointed in us.
Alright.
You think he's gonna bring a second guy, like, in the... Oh,
no, I guess not.
There was that one photo that we...
The hacker man gave us.
Hello!
We expected better from you.
You're a disappointment to everyone!
Your father was the same.
Your father was good at his job, but he was an idiot who put
his family first.
That's why we had to cut ties with him and you lock him in a
cell but he knew too much so we did what had to be done and
his repeated mistakes led him to his own end and now you're
walking the same path i hope you don't make the same
mistakes next time until we meet again
have your memory erased and returned to day one
So it wasn't the good end.
I guess the other end.
Wait, that's kind of so stinky though that they're like, by
the way Like I didn't sign up for this.
They just they just throw it in on us
Yay, that was photomaly photomaly photomaly yay
So that was fine.
I liked it.
I liked it a lot Help
I really like the cat anomaly So you can enjoy a treat
afterwards I will Actually, I just remembered too I have
something to do in 30 minutes So I'm going to go rush I'm
going to go rush Getting food I have a meeting in 30 So
thank you guys so much Thank you, thank you, thank you Sorry
to play in skedaddle But I will see you guys Hopefully Oh,
my schedule for the week will be up probably tomorrow
morning but I will be streaming tomorrow thanks for sharing
this with us happy fooding thank you thank you thank you so
much and oh my gosh oh my god thank you so much for the pink
oh gosh it's too much thank you though I kept sending
pictures of this mind blowingly spooky and cute and not only
in the lower right of my screen but agent 47 kept telling me
not to waste his time reminding me to wipe that guy's memory
when I can't connect Good night, good night, good night.
Thank you so much for the bake.
Take care, Minto.
This for ice cream.
Nami!
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you so much.
Yes, I will go eat.
Otsumito, everybody.
I hope you enjoyed this one.
It was a lot of fun.
And, yeah, get some good respect.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Otsumito, everybody.
Bye-bye.
And sweet dreams.
you